mais que se passe-t-il vous n'aurez pas
du tout c'est vraiment un set up like
que j'utilise pour faire une vidéo sur
ma chaîne youtube mais pourquoi et bien
parce que mon studio est actuellement en
travaux
écoutez moi bien dans l'année vous savez
combien de fois les voisins on perd
c'est un truc 0 ça va pas manquer
tournée chez moi du coup aujourd'hui
nouveau format cette année j'ai envie un
peu de parler de ce qui m'entoure de ce
dans quoi je baigne toute l'année à
savoir internet à savoir youtube pour
une raison très simple je pense que mon
avis importe énormément les gens les
gens veulent savoir ce que je pense
vraiment c'est sûr je sais que c'est
prendre des risques mais je pense aussi
à évoluer à un moment donné c'est ce
père qui fait de plus j'ai la sainte
parole
je ne me trompe jamais eu lieu le
pyramid si les ok on a abordé deux
sujets ensemble à si vous
confortablement moi je me pose en haut
d'un vol comme actuellement le premier
c'est le craquage descendants youtuber
en plein life de david la page vous
connaissez tous bien évidemment personne
charmante david a récemment faire live
24 heures voilà comme de toit de ce
crime à fond et c'est assez intéressant
ça crée une proximité avec la communauté
bref c'est un truc qui se fait dans le
string game sauf que douche froide
il y avait pas grand monde sur l'âge de
début de la fin du coup il a pensé que
c'était peut-être un bug de youtube donc
il a relancé son live
sauf que après avoir relancé le nombre
de vues heures n'a pas changé c'était
approximativement vraiment le même biais
alors un mec qui s'est rendu sur la vie
de david lafarge et qui lui a dit mec
c'est pas buggé c'est juste qu'il ya
personne sur son live ce qui en soi est
est vrai mais ça sert à quoi de
l'envoyer comme ça dans la tête du gars
c'est horrible stupide et je monte à
tous les gens qui n'avaient pas remarqué
que tu bide que tu bid qui alors faire
du coup après avoir lu ce message david
il a un peu pété un câble et on peut le
comprendre
b slave song nique ta [ __ ] de merde
voilà tout ce que j'ai à dire frérot
vraiment si je te croise rohul amin la
main coûte moins cher ou bien s'il te
croit savoir qui c'est d'ailleurs la
farine à virelles la wanna go voilà
[Musique]
walla walla david personne n'a de doute
on sait très bien dans la vraie vie tu
es un gars très sympa très cool qui se
prend pas la tête
alors ne fait pas de voir côté le patron
la mafia en vo rigole mais pourquoi je
vous demande ça bon déjà parce que c'est
un peu drôle et aussi parce que ça
relève un vrai délire je trouve que
david villa il a eu un peu le chemin
clichés de youtube heures dans le sens
où c'est un gars normal le succès lui
tombe dessus
il se met à exploiter l'opening de
booster pokémon dans son kart et il en
fait encore encore et encore sachant que
ça a du succès et que ça buzz en se
posant la question jusqu'à corps ça va
marcher avant que ça s'épuise visé je
sais plus combien de vidéo c'était
incroyable je croyais en mes t2 par jour
pendant un moment donc s'enfermer dans
un format de vidéo qui marche et pas
trop s'en sortir parce que dès que tu en
sors les stades sont nulles et satanique
le moral ça fait mal quoi bref c'est
assez triste mais l avantage de ça c'est
que ça au vu des réactions incroyable en
live comme celle ci mais aussi comme
celle ci est moyen mais derrière moi
aussi n'importe qui sur fort night qui
est dans les trois derniers vivent agi
comme ça arrêté ne lui jetez pas la
pierre
bref j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire je
passe il me souvient exprimé parce que
je vais un peu en impôts mais voilà je
trouve ça un vrai au delà d'un clip un
peu drôle de 20 secondes qui avait plus
d'audience que son live sur twitter
l'homme
ça montre ce dont tout lé youtuber
actuellement qui marche ont peur la
chute la chute des stades la chute de
l'audience
les gens qui se mettent à se battre et
mouiller de toi oh mon dieu j'ai vu pas
mal de gens juste rire face à saez birol
pauvre mec mais en vrai voilà c'était a
besoin de contextualiser et de se mettre
à sa place en phase de chaud ce matin à
la place des autres tout mais prennent
des risques comme moi en faisant cette
vidéo voilà ça vous a plu
une note sur 10 dès maintenant alesi
choisissez attendait qu'elle est une âme
qu'est ce qui se passe là
non non le troisième du youtube heures
de france dévoile son salaire en vidéo
et non c'est juste du gros clic beit
comme ben ammar était erronée tout ce
que je sais on voulait y croire
on voulait que ça arrive mais non en
revanche vous avez toujours rêvé de
mener un business bien juteux et de
devenir riche
thibault vous dites on est contre il est
plus grand secret sur l'entreprise et
son business
regardons ça ensemble aussi surprenant
que ça puisse paraître youtuber
aujourd'hui c'est considéré comme un
vrai métier ça fait au moins trois ans
que c'est le cas ce qui veut dire qu'il
faut se déclarer aux yeux de l'état
avoir sa propre société et déclarer tous
les revenus qu'on gagne aux impôts sait
jamais même quand youtuber n'était pas
vu comme un vrai métier
il fallait quand il fallait quand même
faire ça en fait quand tu gagnes de
l'argent que ton métier ne soient
reconnus ou pas il faut une structure
pour l'encaisser les structures qui vous
permet à l'état de prendre sa part voilà
c'est comme ça que l'opinion générale
considère que ce que tu fais est un vrai
métier ou non on s'en bat les couilles
ça n'a rien à voir
personnellement je gagne ma vie de cinq
manières différentes
les revenus youtube les revenus de mon
sponsor de compléments alimentaires nay
protège les droits d'auteur lui avais
vidéo dans cette vidéo nous allons donc
essentiellement nous consacrer sur la
marque de vêtements team shape il y en a
pour tout le monde
petit me dit ados et enfants et adultes
au corps d'enfant il y a des t-shirts
des pulls des débardeurs des dieux
guille et des shorts des strings et bolo
deschamps moi tu vois c'est une vidéo
sur ta boutique ou sur combien tu gagnes
d'argent maïs et des brasiers il y a
aussi des accessoires comme des stickers
déco cappone des tabliers
[Musique]
des mugs des shakers des bracelets des
salles des serviettes des drapeaux des
livres des casquettes etc à vapeur des
bougies elle est des cerfs-volants les
choses pierre combien tu gagnes demo pas
mais on n'est qu'à trois minutes sur 11
sa va arriver calmons nous ne perdons
pas patience il va le dire à la fin
comme ça il aura boubouch times et sa
vidéo elle sera très mise en avant par
youtube un vrai patron d'entreprise
après forcément les produits que je
dédicace son ultime plus cher car je
peux pas supporter ma journée allait
signer un par un par un attendez on peut
acheter une bd dédicaces et qui coûte
plus cher qu'une bd non dédicacé il est
question de ça
[Musique]
la signature de thibaut vos 2 euros
attendait j'en avoir une idée de
business là découvrez tous les objets du
quotidien morgue chaussures jean
dédicacé par squeeze au même prix que
les objets du quotidien
mugs jeans chaussures
mais pour 2 euros plus passer les
commandes vie mexes et ses limites
l'arbre le team la dédicace à se fait
gratuitement en fait c'est un effort que
le créateur fait pour faire kiffer ces
femmes mais monétiser sa signature je
trouve ça un peu limite dans ce cas là
par contre c'est archi rentable sur mon
site
on retrouve aussi les vidéos
personnalisées ou pour 36 euros jeudi
tout ce que vous voulez en 15 secondes
là je trouve que c'est un moralement on
est sur un truc extra limites quand même
c'est à dire faire des vidéos dédicace
que tu fais payer 36 euros et qui seront
destinés pour la plupart à des mineurs
jeudi air france surtout les jeunes qui
sont attirés par ce genre de trucs les
gens un peu plus et vont plus vouloir
voir un spectacle
un concert un truc un peu plus
entertainer si je peux dire que juste
une vidéo de 15 secondes où tu dis bah
regarder où tu dit ça ya un exemple sur
le site guen david c'est thibault et
chip
j'ai une petite vidéo pour te dire que
c'est toi qui es le meilleur bon courage
dans ta perte de poids on pense fort à
toi tu as le soutiennent en mai sec de
toute la team shape et n'oublie pas que
c'est toi qui es le meilleur
alors l'équipe mathis toiture alors à
toi toi tu es le boss tu es le boss des
années 30 il a été le boss mathis aurait
dit si ce qui pose problème c'est pas le
fait que thibault il va y gagner de
l'argent tout le monde y gagne l'argent
n'est pas que j'en crois que c'est ça
qui vous lui reprochez du tout
d'ailleurs je parle beaucoup avec il
faut aller lui reprocher quoi tu sois je
suis pas du tout cette vidéo pour que
les gens aillent chez thibault derrière
et qui se passe est harcelé ici le souci
c'est que moralement c'est un peu limite
de faire payer une vidéo dédicacé à des
gens surtout quand elle coûte 36 balma
qui est le prix d'une place de concert à
bercy pour un show d'une heure et demie
qui a coûté des centaines de milliers
d'euros d'installation pour certains là
on parle lui d'une vidéo de 15 secondes
dédicace un peu vide mais après dans les
faits il ya des gens qui sont preneurs
il ya des gens qui sont contents que ça
existe et c'est sûr que ça va faire des
heureux
donc est-ce qu'il faut lui en vouloir de
faire ça ou pas ça va surtout faire de
mal à personne je suis mitigé mais pour
ceux qui comme moi trouve ça un peu cher
pour une vidéo de 15 secondes
thibault à une réponse pour vous alors
taisez vous fermez là maintenant et pour
les personnes qui disent que 36 euros
c'est trop cher et que j'aurais dû les
mettre à 10
croyez moi que même ça coûtait 10 euros
elle trouverait comme ça trop cher bah
non
du coup non peut-être qu'il aurait fallu
commencer par là je sais pas si un jour
vous créez votre business et je vous le
souhaite
qu'importe le prix que vous mettrez si
ce n'est pas de la suite ce sera
toujours trop cher mais non c'est
horrible horrible cette mentalité au
contraire fait en dix ans ce genre de
truc tu ainsi que les gens à trouver ça
pas normal de faire des trucs payant
alors que si c'est normal 6 et les
gypsies c'est moralement correct et
c'est par exemple acheter un vêtement
sur la boutique de thibault ou d'un mode
par exemple il n'ya aucun mal à ça tu es
content tu reçois un pro du custom que
de youtube a préféré à fait c'est cool
c'est un échange qui coule mais ça pose
problème quand il ya une question morale
derrière comme c'est le cas de pas mal
de trucs donc vous avez vu ce n'est pas
un grain de beauté c'est un bouton qui
va devenir blanc dans très peu d'eau
vous posez la question depuis début j'ai
répondu on passe à autre chose de plus
sur ces 36 euros comme pour les
rencontres n'ose pas il faut lever les
chiens non je les impôts et la tva
cette excuse des impôts c'est fou pour
justifier un prix de vente
arrêtez je ne force personne à acheter
mes produits chase tu n'as pas le choix
tu ne peux pas forcer les gens à acheter
quoi que ce soit c'est pas un acte
bienveillant de ta part c'est normal
thibault normal aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que même si un youtube heures
peut gagner correctement sa vie qu'avec
les revenus youtube ce sont des revenus
incertains un mois vous pouvez voir les
3000 euros et l'autre 500 c'est moins
vrai thibault rajoute 1 0
tu ne peux pas regarder les gens dans
les yeux et leur dire que à moi tu peux
gagner 500 et l'autre 3000 quand tu fais
45 [ __ ] de millions de vues par mois
jegham but alors répond à ton titre il
dit nous couvrions tzigane en fait y'a
pas de soucis à donner des chiffres et
où c'est même plutôt cool à but
informatif si tu as envie de dévoiler
une information qui est perçu à savoir
ton salaire mais aimait partager ça avec
les gens c'est cool y en a qui l'ont
déjà fait comme à kiel où il l'a fait il
a vraiment donné les vrais chiffres et
c'est allé voir ses vidéos d'ailleurs si
vous n'êtes que sur ça soit en parle
étaient sincères et transparents soit
n'en parle pas et il n'y a pas de souci
mais tu peux pas faire un entre-deux tut
approprient le mérite d'en parler des
transparents contrairement aux autres
sauf qu'en réalité tu leur mets un
énorme boule cheetah la gueule thibault
je suis moi aussi youtuber je fais moi
aussi beaucoup
et je sais que l'on gagne bien plus que
ça à chaque mois je le dis tu ne peux
pas mentir aux gens comme ça non sans
compter les revenus du t4 autre piste
sans parler du nombre des vidéos que
youtube heures se font démonétisé chaque
jour ça c'est vrai je me suis moi aussi
fait démonétisé pas mal de vidéos mais
ça va pas pour être transport avec vous
ça quasiment pas changé mes revenus
youtube parce que c'était
essentiellement des vieilles vidéos et
du coup elles font très peu de vues
chaque mois
donc même si elle ne génère pas d'argent
ça fait pas un gap immense entre avant
et après mais peut-être que tu qu il
s'est fait démonétisé des vidéos très
récente auquel cas c'est vrai ça change
vraiment ce que tu peux toucher
tout ça pour dire que ce soit en france
ou ailleurs dès qu'on affiche qu'on
gagne de l'argent en faisant quelque
chose qu'on aime c'est mal vu mais si
vous travaillez dur et que vous gagnez
de l'argent
personnellement je n'ai pas honte de
dire que je vis de ma passion et si je
fais cette vidéo c'est pour vous aider
vous donner les clés pour essayer fois
ci à faire la même chose que moi c'est
pour ça que je vous motive a perdu bref
bullshit ajd terminer mon t-shirt team
in shape et commander blague à part je
n'ai rien de personnel contre e thibault
du tout ni condamné ni contre quiconque
dont je parlais sur cette chaîne youtube
c'est juste que je pense qu'il est temps
en 2019 après je sais pas combien
d'années de youtube eux qu on soit tous
hein ça avec les gens qu'on soit honnête
avec les gens qu'on voit ceux des vrais
discours voilà c'est pas du tout dans
une démarche malveillantes que j'ai fait
cette vidéo qui parle de thibault et de
david qui ont je trouve c'était deux
actu intéressante à décrypter comme ça
dans cette vidéo et d'en parler en plus
j'ai tapé les bonnes barjols admettent
bref bonne continuation ou youtube
heures qui ont regardé cette vidéo
attention à ne pas tomber dans les
pièges de youtube
soyez sincère et des discours honnête
moi le premier je m'engage aussi eu
voilà je peux être moralisateur ou quoi
que ce soit mais je trouve ça
intéressant de parler d'autres comme ça
surtout quand il ya un vrai background
un vrai contexte
vous me direz ça vous a plu ces cas
n'était pas venir dans les commentaires
[Musique]
ans
oh